school can be overwhelming never-ending
assignments after school activities
early mornings while the list goes on
but it is still very important for you
to stay active and eat well okay
so here's a really quick 10 minute total
body toning workout which you can do
first thing in the morning before you
head to class so get your body warmed up
and let's do this workout together to
kick that your metabolism
it's going to be a total body workout
okay so each workout will be for 45
seconds long with 15 seconds to rest in
between only 10 minutes give me your
best effort and let's do this so the
first workout will be a squat a nice
deep squat with a curtsy lunge to the
side okay and let's go squat
curtsy to the side and now the other leg
squat and curtsy to the side very good
so push your butt back open up your
chest and feel your legs working feel
your butt working squat curtsy to the
side nice deep squat go low but do not
hunch forward
squat and to the side twist feel your
hips working squat down and feel your
hips working good down and curtsy
very nice
so the deeper you go the more you will
feel on your legs
this is a really good total body workout
work on major muscles that's how you
will tone up quicker go deep
and courtesy very good now stand in the
middle of your mat okay we want to do
forward to back lunge so start on your
left leg okay i want you to take a wide
step forward into a lunge and
immediately step back okay let's start
with your left leg first so why step
forward lunge down take a step back
lunge and forward
good
if you want to you can step
bring it forward
take a small step to balance yourself
and take a small step and balance good
as you progress forward and back
forward and back one more good now let's
change side forward
and back good
forward
and back very nice find your balance
take a wide step lunge forward and go
back
forward
and back
keep going step
and back
do more step wide
bring it back
one more step wide and shake it out
let's do white squad with side crunch
okay so step wide i want you to point
your toes out i want you to give me a
nice wide deep squat as you come up
crunch to the side that's it let's go
wide through your inner thighs crunch
feel your obliques good and crunch up
nice feel your inner thighs your
obliques
down
and your obliques push your butt back
with your squats always remember push
your butt back
squeeze your glutes as you come up and
open up your chest good step wide
good feel your inner thighs okay the
wider you step the more you will feel on
your inner thighs good keep going
wide
and squeeze
wide and bring your knee high up
good high knee elbow to knee nice
wide
crunch
balance crunch tighten your core down
and up very good now
at the end of your mat okay let's work
on upper body and core it's going to be
an inch worm with
shoulder tap okay got that let's go
slowly inch forward
all the way give me a right
left
and slowly inch back
the reason why i love this workout is
because you're feeling your hamstrings
as well so stretch out your hamstrings
first thing in the morning inch forward
push it into the ground left
right and slowly inch back
do not bend your knees
up good
inch forward keep going
very good for your hamstrings find your
core balance do not
twist your hips okay
keep them in line with your entire body
up
go down
forward
stretch stretch stretch stretch left
right strong core
and bring it back
breathe in and breathe out still working
on your upper body let's get into a
push-up with a twist so get back down
i want you to give me one solid push-up
and twist
good solid push-up and twist if this is
too difficult remember you can always
start on your knees nice good push up
and rotate the rotation means you're
working on your core strength and also
your obliques good balance push up
balance tighten your core and twist
very good down
and twist
keep going upper body strength is
extremely important and we tend to
neglect it up and twist you're doing
well remember it is only 10 minutes
before the start of your class and your
day twist
and relax
ah
next bear jacks okay so same thing in a
plank position as you jack in i want you
to bend your knees okay so start in a
plank position as you drag in bend your
knees okay out in bend your knees
squeeze a core and that's how you find
your balance that's how you will be
working more on your core squeeze
and remember push into the ground relax
your shoulders out and in
jack out and check in very good
feel your lower abs your upper abs
working
halfway there
this will also bring
your heart rate up
keep going squeeze
bend your knees
hold it
nice keep going you're doing a good job
let's get sweaty before the start
of your day
nice
a few more
one more and
breathe
reverse plank okay let's get into
reverse plank so we all know plank now i
want you to sit
with your arms pointed forward
okay stay on your heels and give me a
nice reverse plank so up push it up
bring it down and push it up
bring it down nice and controlled push
it up squeeze your glutes squeeze your
hamstrings
feel your legs working
good keep going
on your heels
squeeze relax your upper body
and allow your upper body to just
support you
up if you want to challenge yourself
bring it down
up
bring it down balance on one leg and
switch side down
up
down
up very good okay change
down
up
down
up once more change down
up
down and up nice
you are almost there let's go
four times abs okay let's lie on the
floor
and let's work on your abs
right so relax
your arms by your side
okay both legs up
left
right
left right do not bring it down left
right
left right
right
left
right
left that's it feel
the intensity and the contraction on
your lower abs good
alternate do not rest your legs on the
floor okay it's all about squeezing
engaging your abs
and feel them working together
up
up
down
down
up
up
down down keep your leg straight
few more down
down
up
up
down
down last one and just relax okay
staying in this position let's work more
on your obliques bicycle crunches okay
open up your chest bring your legs up
and i want you to twist and work on your
obliques okay got that let's go twist
and point your toes bring your knee to
your elbow bring them close
and keep flowing feel your obliques feel
your lower abs your upper abs working
together so point and point do not rest
your legs on the floor remember to lift
your shoulders
off the floor very good keep twisting
feel the contraction on your core
muscles okay work them
it is important to have a strong core
even from a young age keep going keep
twisting keep pointing
very good last few more you got this
point
point
and
relax for a little while and let's get
back up okay
now final workout let's work on plank it
is a really simple workout but it is
really effective for your core okay so
now get into a plank position
elbows on the floor okay flat back and
just focus on
engaging your core muscles okay do not
lift them too high up this is wrong do
not arch your lower back this is wrong
as well so bring it up
flat back
toes together and just
push
your elbows into the floor relax your
shoulders don't let them dip okay relax
your shoulders and just focus on
engaging your core if you want to we can
challenge ourselves by lifting one leg
off but do not twist this is wrong keep
them straight
and change side very good remember hips
should be in line okay do not drop your
hips
and
you're done
very very well done so that was a really
quick 10 minutes workout but as you can
see i am sweating and it should feel
really good okay i'm sweating but i feel
energized and i can start my day
remember this a really simple workout
you don't need a lot of space you can do
it in your room as well get this workout
done at least three to four times weekly
on alternate days if you want to you can
even do it every single day it's only 10
minutes okay look after your health from
a young age eat well nourish your body
with good food and it will help with
your growth and development and remember
it is very important for you to stay
active all right be sure to like this
video subscribe to my youtube channel if
you haven't yet done it and check out a
lot more workout videos which you can do
and also a lot more fitness and
nutritional tips which will help with
your teenage years all the best